[Music]
on this friday night disappointing deja
vu from traveling to holiday gatherings
restrictions are returning as omicron
tightens its grip we must take steps now
to slow the rapid spread of this variant
what this means for those short road
trips to the u.s where the president has
a dire warning we are looking at a
winner of severe illness and death
unvaccinated a ten-year-old afghan girl
murdered by the taliban this should
shock the conscience of every canadian
her death ignites new urgency for canada
to act faster and sounding the alarm
about wild pigs
why scientists say these feral hogs are
ecological train wrecks
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is becoming clearer just how rapidly
the omicron variant is spreading case
numbers are surging in multiple
provinces and public health restrictions
are being reimposed in several provinces
last week more than 5 000 daily coveted
cases including delta were reported
across canada that is 45 percent higher
than the previous week and omicron is
quickly accelerating the spread today
ontario premier doug ford announced that
starting on sunday most indoor public
settings including bars restaurants and
grocery stores will be reduced to 50
percent capacity and indoor social
gatherings will be limited to ten people
the experts have been very clear
nothing will stop the spread of omicron
it's just too transmissible
what we can do
and what we're doing is slowing it as
much as possible to allow more time for
shots to get into arms
bc and pei are putting in restrictions
again more on that in just a moment and
the federal government is making changes
to its travel rules ending the ban on
travel from 10 african countries and
reinstating pcr tests for short trips
across the border abigail beeman is with
me from ottawa abigail let's start with
those new restrictions in ontario well
donna people across ontario need to
rethink holiday plans in light of these
new restrictions they will affect
everything from how many people you can
host to lining up at grocery stores once
again for your supplies to how late you
can stay out at a restaurant with a cap
on the number of people in your party
and the guidance to get together with
fewer people this christmas and new
year's is not just being given in
ontario but right across the country
get used to seeing these long lines for
newly available rapid tests my parents
are going to visit my grandmother
for
christmas and they want to make sure
that they're not going to be bringing
her
covered as provinces step up
restrictions and make changes to try and
lessen the omicron onslaught public
health reached capacity several days ago
and now our testing program
and the lab have also reached capacity
many of you who are positive will have
to self-manage your case
without hands-on support from public
health it's clear omicron will not take
a holiday it's important for people to
realize that this is very both dramatic
and critical the federal government
announced changes too lifting the flight
ban on people coming from 10 african
nations and reinstating a pcr return
test requirement for people who leave
the country for less than 72 hours if
it's to discourage people saying oh
you're going to have to have the hassle
of having a molecular test
that doesn't seem to have much
much science
the health minister and doctors didn't
offer scientific evidence for the new
tests nor would they say whether that's
the last change coming before the
holidays things
will continue to change unless the
situation doesn't change and new
information doesn't arrive no things
will keep
being
adjusted people coming from the u.s
still don't have mandatory arrival tests
for now preparing to increase
significantly the capacity around the
land border
with the united states there are
currently nearly 350 cases of omicron
across 11 provinces and territories so
far all cases are asymptomatic or mild
dr teresa tam says we still don't know
enough yet about omicron's severity and
even if it is more mild it is so
transmissible that even a
small num small rate of severe outcomes
could result in a high enough
hospitalization rate that it can
overwhelm the system
dr tam is asking canadians to carefully
consider and adjust holiday plans and
more provinces are taking steps to
discourage canadians from gathering in
large groups but this time around public
health leaders understand they're up
against not just the new variant but
extreme covet fatigue from a population
done with restrictions donna all right
abigail beamon in ottawa thanks british
columbia is also reimposing restrictions
dr bonnie henry says she knows it's
going to be discouraging for people but
as of monday limits on indoor personal
gatherings are back and all organized
new year's eve events will be canceled
keith baldry is with me from victoria
keith what is christmas going to look
like in bc
it's going to look a little like last
christmas when we also had health orders
in place so basically small and
uncrowded the key here is to prevent
people from gathering in large numbers
in indoor settings so like ontario
limiting to just 10 the number of people
allowed in your household or members
from one other household uh 50 capacity
in large venues which means only half
the crowd allowed at vancouver canucks
games or junior hockey games as well a
suspension of all sporting events all
sporting tournaments in bc which means
that traditional youth hockey
tournaments that often take place in
most promises in bc will not be allowed
until the end of january when this
health order expires a big impact on the
canucks of course uh no more sold
crowds there with a 15 capacity but
we're not going as far as ontario's
going in terms of restricting activities
in restaurants there's no limit
on alcohol sales cutoffs there's no
limit on capacity
reductions in hospital so again matching
ontario and some restrictions not going
as far in others donna all right keith
baldry in victoria bc thanks
the numbers do paint the picture of how
fast omicron is spreading ontario and
quebec are both reporting more than 3
000 new cases today quebec nova scotia
and pei recorded their highest daily
caseloads since the start of the
pandemic manitoba and prince edward
island are also limiting personal
gatherings to 10 people pei's chief
public health officer says the variant
spreads with very little contact and
every day counts
we will not be able to stop omicron or
prevent its impacts however we must take
steps now to slow the rapid spread of
this variant
the uk is ahead of canada and for a
third consecutive day it set a new
record for covid19 infections more than
93 000 new cases were reported there
today a nearly 60 percent increase in
daily infections compared to a week ago
london is a hot spot and
hospitalizations there have risen by a
third in a week new modeling that has
not been peer reviewed suggests without
more restrictions it's possible deaths
could begin to rise fast and reach 5 000
a day later this winter
across europe countries are reimposing
restrictions to try to slow the spread
starting monday people in switzerland
will be required to work from home
unvaccinated people will be barred from
many public venues in denmark theaters
museums and concert halls will close and
in ireland there will be an 8 p.m curfew
in pubs and restaurants starting sunday
in the u.s an omicron surge is now
considered inevitable and cities like
new york and washington are reporting
record high numbers in the last 24 hours
hospitalizations are on the rise and
restrictions are slowly coming back in
some places as jackson prescott reports
the most urgent warnings are for the
unvaccinated
in a return to the early days of the
pandemic long lines for covid testing
are back across the u.s amid surging
case counts and dire warnings for
unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death unvaccinated
as americans prepare to travel in record
numbers for the holidays
the omicron variant is rapidly taking
hold here too
mixing with an existing surge of delta
variant cases that had already pushed
many hospitals to the brink these
patients do not improve overnight they
do not improve over days it's weeks and
weeks and weeks at a time experts have
warned omicron cases risk swapping
hospitals and sidelining large numbers
of doctors and nurses if you have a lot
of hospital workers nurses and doctors
and icu staff calling in sick at home
because they have symptomatic covit
that's going to really tax an already
strained health system
already there are signs of what may soon
come
major sports leagues have started
postponing games with dozens of players
and staff testing positive
in new york parts of broadway have gone
dark again
the city's famous new year's eve
celebration may have to be scaled back
with transmission already fueling record
high cases we're going to watch very
carefully it's still you know more than
two weeks away and if at any point we
need to alter the plan we will if
vaccination is a leading defense the u.s
is in a world of trouble just 61 percent
of eligible americans are fully
vaccinated only 30 percent have had
booster shots get vaccinated and get
boosted
mask in public indoor settings physical
distancing hand washing
improved ventilation and testing to slow
transmission that advice is unlikely to
stave off a dark and worrying winter
with models suggesting a nation that has
recorded more than eight hundred
thousand covet deaths could surpass 1
million lives lost by the spring
jackson prosko global news washington
questions about ottawa's response after
a young afghan girl was killed by the
taliban while her family waited to come
to canada that's coming up
[Music]
we are getting lots of reaction to a
story jeff semple filed yesterday about
the death of an afghan girl ten-year-old
nazifa was killed last week by the
taliban her father used to work for the
canadian military and the family was
approved to come to canada they were on
their way to get passports when the girl
was killed as jeff reports tonight her
death is raising questions about why the
family wasn't rescued sooner
canadian veteran robin rickards is
delivering a housewarming gift to
thunder bay's newest residents this
family of afghan refugees
rickard served three tours in
afghanistan alongside interpreter
muhammad zarif as the taliban took over
last summer zarif's family escaped to
pakistan but their happy reunion is
being overshadowed by the news about
ten-year-old nazifa the afghan girl was
also preparing to come to canada before
she was killed by the taliban an
entirely preventable tragedy the folks
that worked with us the folks that
worked hard for us them and their
families are left behind and increasing
numbers of them are being killed
and it's as simple as that and the
government refuses to do anything
mazefa's father worked alongside the
canadian military and the family was
approved to go to canada they'd made the
long drive to kandahar to apply for
passports which could have allowed them
to escape to pakistan
but after driving through a taliban
checkpoint last week one of the guards
suddenly started firing at the vehicle
nazifa was shot in the head
i am begging the canadian government to
help us her father says not just my
family but all the others who supported
canada's mission if we're not evacuated
soon this will happen again this should
shock the conscience of every canadian
is unconscionable and it is
the kind of thing that motivates us to
do more and more global news asked the
immigration minister what more the
government will do to help those who
helped canada and are still trapped in
afghanistan we're dealing with a
territory that's been seized by as i
said the taliban a terrorist entity
we're dealing with a complete lack of
access to a working airport but kabul's
airport is operational and the taliban
has so far not prevented afghans with
canadian visas from leaving canada's
conundrum is where and how to process
their biometrics and security checks
with no diplomatic presence in the
country telling people that they need to
go and get the necessary documentation
and the visas and the passports and the
bureaucratic red tape is not going to
work and that's going to cost lives a
new special committee of mps met for the
first time this week and is
investigating the government's handling
of the afghanistan crisis which will now
include questions about nazifa's case we
need answers from the trudeau government
as to why this was allowed to happen in
the meantime bashir his wife and other
children are mourning the loss of their
bright little girl as they wait for the
taliban to issue their passports jeff
semple global news toronto
as omicron cases surge what can you do
to protect yourself ahead we take your
questions to the experts
well it is beyond exasperating that
we're back into this phase of the
pandemic back to trying to figure out
what this virus is capable of we do want
to try to answer some of your questions
first there's some new modeling from
imperial college london today which used
data from england and it shows omicron
largely evades immunity from past
infection or to vaccine doses it
estimates risk of re-infection from
omicron is more than five times greater
than that of the delta variant and that
implies any protection afforded by past
infection may be as low as 19 percent
and vaccine effectiveness is between
zero to twenty percent after two doses
between fifty five to eighty percent
after a booster dose that study not been
peer reviewed yet with me from halifax
is dr lisa barrett an infectious disease
and human immunology expert dr barrett
thanks for being here
you know we thought getting double
vaxxed was going to get us out of this
oh macron is a game changer what is the
single best thing canadians can do now
well believe it or not the single best
thing canadians can still do is get
vaccinated even though you've presented
those numbers there are still variants
of other types around and you know what
55 to 80 protection and probably about
that amount from death and
hospitalization
is still a heck of a lot better than not
being vaccinated and so right now
vaccination is the key thing
layered in with a little bit of
moderation for our upcoming holidays two
good things for canadians to do and
getting that third dose especially is
what's key right now
for sure if you have access to a third
dose that's very important
i want people to understand though very
clearly that we have a whole tool box
and and there are wins compared with
this time last year going into the
holidays we have a toolbox now that we
can use that includes booster doses or
third doses of vaccine it includes
knowing that masking ventilation and
some distance work as well as keeping
things outdoors where possible and also
testing where it's available can help us
to fill in the gaps when we don't have
immediate access to boosters so lots of
things you can do
in the meantime to keep yourself safe as
you go forward
pfizer bindex said today its vaccine
failed to produce a potent immune
response in children age two to five and
they are now going to test a third dose
we're not vaccinating kids that young in
canada yet but does this mean the
possibility of that is even further away
two to five year olds are a little
different from an immune perspective and
we'll get it right it's just not quite
there yet so a little more time before
we're gonna probably have access to
those vaccines for those folks all right
here's a question from a viewer who
should worry the most about omicron
right now
well um the information we have is
limited and still coming through uh
there have been lots of almost rumors
that this is not as uh important or
severe a disease and we're not quite
certain about that so right now the best
advice is
presume that you may be susceptible uh
to this to getting this infection and if
you're someone who just like before has
complex medical disease immune
suppression
you're being treated for another cancer
and or that you have underlying lung
disease or
an elevated
body weight those are things you might
want to keep in mind and those might
still be
risks for more severe disease so short
answer we don't quite know about omicron
yet
so
in the worst case scenario let's presume
that those folks are still at higher
risk and keep some extra parts of your
toolbox around for prevention while
we're figuring that out and just super
quick last question follow up when will
we know with certainty whether omicron
leads to mild or serious illness
excellent question i'm dying to find out
myself there are emerging pieces of
information from other countries that
have seen more of this omicron for
longer but it is a bit of a time game we
need to see in the real world
what happens with people who are
vaccinated with the vaccines that we use
here in canada and right now we don't
know but over the next three to four
weeks i think we're going to gain a heck
of a lot more information and will be
much better earned in the new year to
know exactly what's going on prudence
until then and no presumption
all right dr lisa barrett thank you
big bores bigger problems next the
threat wild pigs pose to canada's
ecosystems
you don't need me to tell you there are
plenty of things to worry about these
days but you may not have this one on
your radar wild pigs they've become one
of the most invasive mammals on the
planet and are common in lots of places
in canada now including saskatchewan as
mike relay explains farmers and
researchers are sounding the alarm about
what an ecological nightmare they
are
to the casual observer this is nothing
more than wildlife a wild boar tending
to her new litter of piglets
but wildlife experts don't see canadian
bacon they see a pig not native to north
america which could soon become an
ecological train wreck for the country
they are the worst invasive large mammal
on the planet ryan brook is one of
exactly two canadian researchers
tracking the swine spread wild boars
were first imported from europe by
farmers in the 1980s some escaped and
they were first seen in the wild in the
1990s over the following two decades
they spread steadily throughout the
prairies but it's since 2010 that
researchers have seen exponential growth
in their habitat and they've now been
spotted in ontario and quebec
earlier this month a family of 14 pigs
called a sounder was caught and
euthanized in pickering just outside of
toronto
why does any of this matter
[Music]
well authorities are now trapping wild
pigs on the streets of hong kong as well
as throughout europe and the u.s they
destroy crops eat pretty much anything
they can find and can transmit swine
fever to wildlife and humans alike in
ontario they're now an invasive species
all the restaurants they were really
really disappointed
actually a lot of people were shocked
after 20 years in business hans
lindemann has been told by the ontario
government to wrap up his wild boar
breeding operation he says there was no
consultation and no option to create
stricter regulations i totally know that
because i'm from switzerland because
they're
the the government pays millions of
dollars each year for compensations
for the damage they do i know the
problem
but
they should have done it differently you
know they should have imposed the
fencing rules for all the fear brooks
says the wild pig population continues
to grow and we're past the point of
eradicating them
wild pigs because they have two litters
per year six young in each litter on
average
their growth is so high that you just
can't barbecue your way out of a wild
pig problem but we can he says learn
from the us and europe and do our
darndest to contain them
mike trollite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the fisherman's memorial
lobster pot christmas tree in leading
tickles newfoundland and labrador love
that and we'd love to see your canada
too especially festive pictures please
email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
well i'm taking some time off for the
holidays i hope you and your loved ones
are able to as well and can make the
most of what's possible where you live
thanks for making time for us every
night and on behalf of everyone here at
global national stay safe take care of
yourselves and find joy where you can
i'll see you again in 2022 bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you